after three years closed to the world
China is about to open up but new travel
freedoms have sparked new coveted fears
and England has become the latest to
introduce pre-departure covid tests for
those coming from the region it's a
swift change in approach after days of
ministers suggesting new measures may
not be necessary despite a surge in the
country's covered cases this was the
health Minister just yesterday there's
no evidence at this point of a new
variant from China a variant that is not
already prevalent here in the UK but
nevertheless we're keeping the situation
very much under review
the shift brings the UK into line with
the US Japan India Spain Italy and
others
and follows days of meetings between
ministers and health officials but it's
about much more than just Public Health
number 10 say it's also about the lack
of reliable covered data coming from
Beijing I think that there is possibly
an element putting pressure on the
Chinese to to to get better data and
then to release it but there is also the
point that there are a large number of
infections in China and we don't really
know what's causing them a global
diplomatic rebuke for president XI
who has already faced a domestic
backlash over his zero covered policy
and with more countries considering
testing arrivals from China it looks
like a global backlash is building as
well Liz Bates Sky News Westminster